this is the guy that I've been waiting  for how are you he knows without a doubt  that he is in love with me and he wants  me to be his wife one day you can see  that darling and I feel like we're  starting to turn the page and enter into  a new chapter of our relationship I had  so much fun today you get Sookie  whenever I started talking about my  feelings for you you like start itching  a little closer and you have like laser  focus  seriously it's it's so attractive and  they feel really good what's on my  marriage this is a huge deal and you  know forever shouldn't be taken lightly  and there's so many things that you know  I want from myself in my future wife  wife you sure that you know I want it  the way I want you know yeah so let's  talk about  you